sono emozionata vi dico la verità mio
marito lo sa Eccolo è lì che mi guarda
alzati Giovanni dai Fatti fare questo
applauso
Anche perché applauso meritatissimo
Considerate che Giovanni negli ultimi
mesi ha perso tantissimo peso e adesso
Guardatelo un figurino sembra un'altra
persona sta benissimo vero
vero
interessante vediamo un po' Quanti di
voi Stanno pensando in questo momento
Quanto vorrei dimagrire alzate le mani
ammazza Ok
benissimo Quanti di voi volevano
dimagrire e ci sono riusciti alzate le
mani Ok quanti volevano dimagrire e non
ci sono riusciti
bene quanti hanno perso peso ma poi lo
hanno ripreso e anche più di prima
come stai bene Hai perso tantissimo peso
Guardati un figurino sembri un'altra
persona ma un'altra In che senso
migliore No perché a me qui un'altra
sembra significhi migliore
e sono proprio queste le parole che
cerchi ogni giorno quando modifichi
quella foto prima di pubblicarla sui
social quando Salvi quella ricetta Fit
che ti promette di toglierti la fame è
ovvio o quando piano ti senti di colpa
con il masochismo del quale è capace
solo il vero dolore vai a prendere quel
paio di jeans che avevi quando avevi 16
anni e sono proprio ad infilare con gli
occhi chiusi sperando che salga almeno
fino alle caviglie
essere una persona migliore è quello che
cerchi ogni giorno quando inizi una
conversazione con il tuo partner
dicendogli come sto Sono dimagrito sono
dimagrita ma esattamente
Da quando ha iniziato a misurare il tuo
valore in grammi e in centimetri perché
questo continuo paragonare perché non ti
dai pace
nel Mercante di Venezia William
Shakespeare scriveva che Antonio era
costretto a pagare un debito a Shylock
di una libera di carne circa mezzo chilo
dal proprio corpo
un debito un debito doloroso doversi
togliere parte di te
un'umiliazione
doversi privare di qualcosa di così
intimo che ci appartiene che ci protegge
dalle intemperie dalle malattie che ci
tiene in vita
in vita il nostro corpo ci tiene in vita
e se oggi volessimo invece riscrivere le
parole del Bardo per noi sarebbe un
premio dover cedere parte del punto vita
dai fianchi da dove ve lo vogliamo
togliere questo mezzo chilo
perché essere magri è diventato un vanto
se starò magro mi vedranno
se sarò abbastanza sottile sarò come
tutti coloro che vengono amati
voglio essere così magro da meritarmi
l'amore
i 500 g di carne che stai pagando di
debito non li prendi dal punto vita non
li prendi dai fianchi
il vuoto che cerchi di riempire
mangiando
o non mangiando
è qui sul cuore
perché essere magri è diventato un vanto
come siamo arrivati a questo punto
Ok partiamo dall'inizio partiamo dallo
stile di vita sano dal mangiare sano
dagli alimenti sani Partiamo dalla
colazione Vi dirò cosa ho mangiato Io
oggi a colazione riprendiamo uno di quei
Trend che adesso va molto di moda sui
social e vi dirò quello che ho mangiato
e spero voi lo possiate replicare come
colazione sana Allora ho mangiato un
cornetto con il cioccolato poi un
cappuccino con il latte intero la
spolverata di cacao della frutta e poi
ha un biscotto che ho preso dal piatto
di Giovanni che si era distratto glielo
ha rubato Ok non c'è trucco Eh non sto
parlando di un cornetto senza uova senza
burro senza zucchero senza cornetto sto
parlando del classico cornetto della
tradizione italiana che mangio da quando
sono piccola e quindi con zuccheri
grassi e come Oh come dire che sia sano
Allora prendi questa frase che sto per
dirti faccio un cartello dentro casa 3x
secolo appendi così non lo guardi con
scritto non esiste cibo sano e cibo non
sano ma il complesso di un'intera
alimentazione stile di vita a
determinare cosa ti fa bene e cosa non
ti fa bene
Anzi una cosa non stava per niente Cioè
sentirti in colpa quando mangi sentirti
in colpa perché mangi è questo il punto
è questa la partenza da qui inizia tutto
il senso di colpa che la cultura della
dieta ha instillato in te per una mera
squallida e unica motivazione di
marketing è questo il punto
se vuoi dimagrire ti vendo cose per
dimagrire
prendi integratori che creo illudendo di
fare meno fatica ti vendo completini
color amaranto che non metterai mai per
motivarti ad andare in palestra invece
di spiegarti che non esiste la
motivazione fine a se stessa Ma esiste
il benessere mentale e se pensi di
starlo perdendo devi rivolgerti ad un
professionista e non comprare comprare
comprare completini color amaranto
ti vendo sedute e trattamenti per il
rassodamento cellulare non abbiamo la
cura per il cancro Ma Signore e signori
abbiamo il rassodamento cellulare
e quando tutto questo fallirà perché
fallirà E tu ti troverai
allo stremo Immerso nei sensi di colpa
perché io non solo ti ho detto che
dovevi essere magro ma dovevi riuscirci
velocemente e senza fatica ti troverai
esattamente come desidero triste Ad un
passo da un disturbo del comportamento
alimentare
da domani niente dieta mi sfondo domani
mi concedo lo sgarro lo sgarro lo sgarro
sappiamo Qual è la definizione che si
trova sul dizionario della parola Sgarro
trascuratezza nell'osservanza di un
dovere venire meno sul piano della
correttezza morale la correttezza morale
cioè esattamente a quale dovremmo morale
staresti venendo meno mangiando una
parmigiana di melanzane
Lo sai qual è l'unico vero dovere
mangiare perché se non mangi e non ci
vuole una laurea in Biologia della
nutrizione per dire questo muori se non
mangi non sopravvivi e la dieta Plank e
le proteine che fanno dimagrire
carboidrati che sono il demonio E devi
mangiare quando fai il pranzo in ordine
le cose perché altrimenti il tuo lo
stomaco È come un campo da te tiri
questo ovviamente e la dieta detox sai
che cosa ti sto menzionando bufale sono
Tutte bufale e non solo solo sciocchezze
sono anche pericolose si chiamano
restrizioni alimentari e no non dieta
dieta significa stile di vita non
significa limite dal greco di Aida
prima ho detto che non esiste la cura
per il cancro
e ad oggi purtroppo questo è ancora vero
ma ne esiste un altro di cancro più
societario comunitario che si insinuate
vittime Anno dopo anno e per questo la
cura c'è la cura sei tu il body shaming
l'ossessione per il peso corporeo la
madre sta a tutti i costi la
celebrazione del dismorfismo Questo è
come un cancro che infetta elementi
infetta le famiglie in sette posti di
lavoro infetta le scuole Le piattaforme
social
E tu come puoi esserne la cura
l'ultima volta è stato un uomo che
veniva dall'Egitto a dettare i dieci
comandamenti sulla cima di una montagna
e oggi
Diciamo Siccome ha avuto un discreto
successo oggi permettete che sia una
donna che viene da Latina a darvene 5 1
combatti le tue fobie un obeso un
sottopeso un normopeso è comunque una
persona non basare i tuoi giudizi su ciò
che non conosci che non ha niente a che
fare con te numero 2
non presumere di conoscere lo stato
fisico o psicologico di una persona dal
suo aspetto fisico una persona minuta o
che abbia difficoltà a mettere una
muscolatura ipertrofica non deve
semplicemente mangiare di più perché tu
lo vedi sciupato così come una persona
normopeso non è detto che non abbia un
disturbo del comportamento alimentare
numero 3 Lascia che siano i medici ad
occuparsi delle cure e delle diagnosi tu
occupati di esserci
per le persone che ne hanno bisogno nei
modi che sono più utili
numero 4 non commentare il corpo degli
altri anche se pensi di fare un
complimento cerca di perdere l'abitudine
di sorridere dicendo sei dimagrito
perché non è un complimento non è un
traguardo da festeggiare Vai sulla mente
a rafforzare la desiderabilità della
magrezza lo stigma grasso fobico secondo
il quale ciò che è magro e anche bello e
quindi ad alimentare disturbi alimentari
numero 5 non smettere mai di leggere ed
informarti combatti le fake news
combatti le bufale studia alimentazione
diffondi consapevolezza studia
alimentazione e di Fondi consapevolezza
Ci sono migliaia di ragazzi e ragazze
che muoiono credendo di non meritare
l'amore perché non assomigliano a quelle
foto e quei video che vedono tutti i
giorni ci sono milioni di persone che
tutti i giorni muoiono dentro
guardandosi allo specchio e non
riuscendo a trattenere le lacrime sei la
loro speranza
affrontare questo discorso non è
semplice così come non lo è Cambiare le
proprie abitudini e per questo voglio
dirti che
ammiro il tuo coraggio perché questa è
una guerra che non risparmia colpi e tu
puoi fare la differenza non c'è limite a
quello che può fare anche una sola idea
che si diffonde in un gruppo di persone
che parte dal desiderio di dare voce
alla scienza e non alla miseria persino
restituire al cuore il suo peso
originale Grazie
[Applauso]